بقى في سياق الحديث عن اعاده الاعمار
وتوفير تكلفتها عرضت رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ارسل لافندر لاين عرضت مقترحه
لمصادره الوصول الروسيه المجمده لتمويل
اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا كما قالت غوندر لاين
ان هناك ايضا مقترحا لانشاء محكمه خاصه
مدعومه من الامم المتحده لمحاسبه روسيا
على جرائمها في اوكرانيا
واشارت لان الاجتهاد الروسيه تسبب في مقتل
اكثر من 20,000 مدني واكثر من 100 الف
جندي اوكراني حتى الان
رقص اجنبي
غير مسبوقه كلنا نتذكر اهوال بوتشا ويقدر
بان اكثر من 20 الف مدني واكثر من مئه الف
جندي تم قتلهم حتى الان على روسيا دفع ثمن
افعلها الفظيعه بما في ذلك جرائمها ضد
دوله ذات سياده لذلك بين ما نستمر في دعم
عمل الجنائيه الدوليه
للحصول على دعم لهذا الامر
وعلى روسيا كذلك دفع تعويضات الماديه جراء
الدمار الذي تسببت فيه والذي يقدر بس 600
مليار